uh today's guest is my friend Caleb
Presley Caleb Presley Mr Caleb Presley
shine that light on
[Music]
me I'll sit and tell you my
stor
shine on
me and I will find a song I will
singing
dude we went hunting man what that was
that was crazy kind of I feel like that
was interesting I guess I mean there the
only two things I ever say that things
are so I say sometimes I say they're
insane oh yeah that's insane it was an
insane trip the thing about barcol dude
is I started working there right at
college right um I went to North
Carolina for college I played fo yeah I
know you played backup quarterback there
you played quarterback sorry I didn't
mean to say no I was backup I was
definitely backup who were you backup to
there so I was back up a lot of people
so I went to college with the most
famous guy I went to college with
quarterback wise was Mitch trabis who's
the quarterback for Chicago Bears I
don't know how much you follow football
yeah I like the bears actually and I
thought Tris was a reachy pick but I
think he has a lot I think he has some
upside I think in the next two years
he's going to have to definitely show it
or he's going to be we had a good he had
a good year last year he's one of my
best friends I was roommates with him in
college we had Queen bunk beds wow what
is that it's a bunk beds but queen size
so it's like bunk beds for men oh wow
why don't we have that ni I'm down yeah
okay King [__] him you guys you guys
live together uh-uh but Nick sleeps in
here sometimes and I don't want him to
feel alone so we'll put an extra bunk
we'll throw an extra bunk dud it was
great for bonding dude I got to be
honest like I I never felt closer to
somebody just knowing he was always
under me
yeah he always had your back or
depending on how you were sleeping um so
when you're there you telling guys like
hey you know I'm his backup you know
pick me you know for supp dude I never I
never backed him up I was always in
front of him because I was older oh so
he was a freshman when I was like uh a
junior and so I was actually second
string when he was red shirting did he
ever have to come out cuz like his shoe
was undone and you had to [__] go in
there dude I don't know how I else to
tell you this but I was in front of him
wow so that never happened oh really
yeah you moved out here to Nashville
how's that been for you it's been good
so far I haven't been here that much MH
uh Falls like the busiest time of the
year for me so I'm traveling but uh I've
liked it so far it's a lot of like they
try to notice if you go downtown you see
a lot of fat stuffed in the boots dude I
I told you that I was like this it's way
fatter than I thought it was going to be
and I mean it's all of but it's there's
a lot of there's a lot of fats out here
oh there is and mostly on the female
side and I'm not even saying not even
looking from a sexual P perspective like
they're just a lot of girls who are
they're on Broadway oh yeah and they're
fat they're thick baby they're thick now
they're thick yeah they Chang it man but
it because it is you know they
definitely fat has become more designer
I think the Kardashians did that because
they had that kind of desert fat that
ass you know did you see the story that
uh Kim apparently like cut her ass off
uhuh it's off now wow and did they do
anything with the meat or whatever I
think they had to of but I don't know
what they did with it what would you
have done with it oh I'm sure she gave
it to blacks man if you've seen like a
lot of her history you know yeah she
does a lot of stuff for like the
African-American community and you think
they would reappropriate it or just eat
it I don't know dude look I'll tell you
this if I got a half pound of uh dashian
ass in the mail bro yeah I might sear it
but I might not cook the whole thing you
know yeah I mean look I'm leaving the
middle of rare I'll be honest bro I am
bro and I think I'm eating it alone yeah
wow yeah you might have to dude honestly
candle light dinner
and and you're going to be hungry
afterwards too for dessert and it's
going to be a hard meal to follow up oh
that's going to be a hard meal to follow
up we went turkey hunting this weekend
and uh we went with Michael wadell and
so he's like one of the best turkey
callers ever so he's got that uh he's
got that verbal on him so you kind of
setting up and then he's he's like in
the distance he's like
uh do it see if you can do
it the funniest thing is he'll be like
all right everyone be real calm these
guys eat they eat ants in dirt for they
can see every of dirt it's what they eat
for a full-time job like yeah they eat
spiders buddy so if they can see that
they can see you we're all sitting dead
still cuz he's telling us and then
meanwhile he's running through the
field he's got the [__] fan
going like dud they can see you for sure
so he's a fake turkey and he holds a
fake turkey in front of him they can't
see him because he's hiding behind this
fake turkey that's about this big he's
holding in front of him like an
invisibility cloak yeah yeah we had like
Five Guys hiding behind a little bitty
fake turkey like it was crazy cuz
Michael wat does not like he don't let a
turkey live he don't want to let a
turkey live he is when he locks in on a
bird he locks in on a bird he's very
very very nice and very very charismatic
to people but he's that you can see does
have that switch oh it [__] switches
after three hours we're like maybe let's
go back and get some breakfast cuz we've
been up since 4:40 in the morning and he
was maybe we stay here yeah [__]
turkeys okay dude we'll stay around for
another minute yeah dude he w i mean if
you even [__] mentioned Thanksgiving
he'll just [__] come on you yeah he
kept on saying all these turkeys want to
do is [__] fight and I was like yeah
is it just a turkey that's who are we
talking about
dude one time I was in uh it was like a
first class first day of class in
Carolina and our teacher handed out a
page of full of quotes like Albert
Einstein Isaac Newton The Gauntlet of
quote people and then one that was just
like I can't remember it was like HB
Scott mhm and she's like raise your hand
and tell me something about one of these
quotes and I raised my hand trying to
get in her good graces I was like HB
Scott's quote is straight up stupid like
it doesn't make any sense and she was
like that's that's
me she was HP Scott yeah she put herself
amongst amongst the
great that's a crazy move dude I
remember when I went in some class and
they told us about uh stonehinge you
know and like what does it mean we're
going to find out and I was like what if
God was just [__] with everybody and
just set some rocks up you know and the
lady's like get out first day and I
thought it was like fun you know like a
fun way to talk about stuff and just as
impossible as anything else we had a guy
one time on here who
beat what's that dis he has like a
disease or something where you can't
talk uh he had a
stutter and
he I I've always want to fight something
hand to hand so I think I it would to me
it seemed like if if I got a blade on me
or a sword even I would go out there and
fight a a turkey but I think you know I
think the little bit of like let me hide
behind this tree yeah and make a sound
of another you know yeah young animal
and we didn't say this but the sound is
like so it's it's basically a horny bird
yeah like we're supposed to be a hen
we're pretending to be a hen right
trying to seduce a horny uh turkey right
that's like say you're at a rest area
right and you go in the there's some
dude out there smoking against the wall
right he's out there just smoking a
cigarette and you go inside the men's
restroom or the women's right and the
window he's smoking right outside of a
window that go where you can inside of
the restroom now and you're like oh come
out come on in here and get this Cooter
baby you know come on in here and uh and
uh just slide up on up in this slick
water it you know you say [__] like that
right yeah and at first he's thinking oh
that's some [__] in there that ain't
real he keeps puffing his [__]
Winston out there and then finally
you're just like you just start yelling
like Oh Come and just snack on these
titty nipples you know and finally he
puts that cigarette out he's like all
right I'm F enough yeah and then right
when he comes
inow yeah you [__] blow his brains
out but this place they have everybody
that works there has Down
syndrome so that's like and people were
giving them a problem but I think it's
kind of cool what could you give them a
problem about I think people are saying
oh this is wrong you know but I think
it's like at least now you can embrace
it like welcome to this place we have
Down syndrome because what I don't like
is when people pretend somebody doesn't
have Down syndrome yeah you know too
many people doing that well in our town
growing up they would do that a lot and
they' be like Eric has down Center
syndrome you know and like no he doesn't
you know like all right well you
know like
well he's not doing great
today yo his service is just slow yeah
at least they're doing it in Europe dude
so serves slow anyways then he didn't
get enough rest you know I mean but uh
pretty crazy I wonder what other
afflictions you could have and also have
like a
cool place you know
oh establishment be incorporated yeah
yeah like if they had what if there was
a what if there was a spot where every
every single person had like
herpes like everyone in here has genital
herpes they serving you [__] a
hamburger hamburgers and herpes
yeah bro what about eggs and eczema you
just go the guy's like oh you want some
salt on that and he just rubs his skin
off like
that dude what about Pepsi no and
hepsi like hey you want something to
drink check your crot yeah that be
it oh what's something that people don't
know about that has Bula guy like do
people what is like I don't think enough
people comprehend that he's Muslim he's
like super religious oh really and so
now what does that mean does he like
when the sun comes out he has to be in a
certain position what is what all like
what is he doing he's not talking to
women he's not photographing with women
he's not in bars like he's not he's in
the United States for the first time
right now he has his visa for the first
time wow so he's in Vegas and I'm sure
like I talked to his people a little bit
I'm sure that he could probably pick up
like insane insane bags just go to like
the wind nightclub or whatever and just
kind of get held up a little bit maybe
punch Steve yoke in the face or
something and get like a million bucks
he can't do it he can't do it why he's
Muslim so like he can't be around
alcohol he can't be and he's serious
about it he's like a serious dude he's
19 so he's like fully developed
brain very serious about life serious
about being Muslim he's funny he's like
I got a good sense of humor he like
likes to have fun but he's like uh he's
he's a devout religious person I don't
think people realize that and do they
put him on a little rug and stuff every
like hour and a half or how does that
work dude it's hilarious actually what
happens is girls will come up to him
he's the most famous person I've ever
been around ever and just like doing
this job for however long interviewing
people who are like celebrities and
stuff you you meet you run into people
you hang out with people who are like
famous and you see people people who
have crazy followings mhm hasbullah is
by far the most famous person I've ever
ever seen Wow when he walks through a
place it's like the whole room just like
just come in on him everyone's trying to
take pictures everyone's like want to
get punch in the face by
him and I think it's because he looks
even if you don't know who he is just by
the look of him you're like that guy
there's something special about that guy
cuz when I first saw him I thought he
was going be like a dwarf like a dwarf
size you know like this tall yeah but
he's three feet he's one football yard
wow he's This Tall oh he's got all that
body and Charisma packed into this size
damn it's like a baby Snicker yeah bro
think about this think about a kid like
this big you just like hold him that's a
gobler huh now think about this what if
you hid behind a like a a bench in the
mall and made some Muslim sounds and
then when he came around the bench he
blew wow that's insane it seems insane
doesn't it dude there's some people in a
mock that would love to do that to a
Muslim bro that's true
dude yeah I definitely you don't have to
drive far around there to hear the NW
like you could just you could be
downwind of anybody in that area you'll
catch it you know Reno is bad
Reno's growing Reno's growing Reno's
growing and uh was the only city I
wouldn't donate blood in dude honestly
cuz I felt bad about leaving it there
really dude I remember one time we met
this Chinese kid and he'd never seen
wrestling before and then we told him it
was two guys trying to [__] each other
right he believed it yeah he believed it
totally but the whole time he's like
he's just like wondering why they
couldn't both do it you know he's like
this seems so crazy yeah still a winner
this is a weird thought yeah do you feel
like horny guys are more fun to be
around even though you're not trying to
[__] them that's a good question dude
sometimes I feel like being around more
guys is
fun just like this guy's amped up right
now dude this guy [__] fired up dude
like I'm bored but this guy is he's got
natural energy he's like yeah I don't
know yeah this guy's spruced up well I'm
not saying that's how I feel I'm just
saying
you look what do you say to people who
say what do you say people say it's fun
to be around horny
first of all if I'm a cult leader good
for me I feel like right yeah I hate how
they're always like oh this [__] cult
leader you know or whoever you know or
like whoever it is Billy Graham or like
Mike Lindell or whoever these people are
you know like uh who the guy that did
the XFL you know all that [__] but it's
like I'm in if I'm a cold leader I'm
[__] let's do it yeah what would you
do for your
cult what would you have them do or what
do they need what do you someone need to
do like once they're in how do you
maintain your membership I think sex
mostly it seems like you you're right on
the same page as pretty much everyone
else I think I mean the only reason you
get into a cold I feel like is probably
for some kind of light sex you know day
dude I really was never much of a
physical specimen I was always more
mental that the the sharp yeah the brain
yeah right that brain that was how I got
there well dude I I used to be friends
with JP losman when he played um T Lane
mhm and he was more physical and I think
he was you know I think he was 5050 on
the mental side which a lot of guys are
less right so maybe that he was good
probably oh dude I met Aaron Brooks one
time at a buffet and he didn't know how
a buffet worked and he was and this was
years after he'd been on the Saints so
he was probably 1090 mental we're
supposed to have ostrich out there that
was one of the big selling points for me
is you guys can come out here and you
know go gun down on a couple stretch out
here
um and I don't know if are ostrich like
trans birds or something they're
very I don't know dude the I mean they I
don't know where they fall I don't know
where they fall I don't know that that
was a true thing that they were supposed
to be out there though yeah the people
in Nashville are awesome yeah awesome
people a lot of unique folks passing
through town yeah um some of the best
gas station hangs yeah you I I go get
coffee every morning at a gas station oh
bro you hit some of these gas stations
you need to go during the owl hours bro
when the [__] owls are out there's
one there's they got two owls land over
there at night yeah and uh there's a guy
out there and he sees the owls he tells
you and then you owe him money appar
right that's a twice daily yeah yeah it
is it's that twice daily that tiger Mark
uh so dude over there bro that dude
[__] you got to pull up just before
he sees those owls if you want to
[__] do it on the cheap sitting
around telling the stories laughing all
that was fun she even sharing in the
same room was fun I when else do you get
to do that as an adult it's like you're
back at like summer camp or something
you know people stay out there just
joking around at night yeah uh you know
people are snoring people are people are
some people are snoring out of their
butt you know what I'm saying
like there's just a lot going on out
there dude you kept waking up in the
middle of the night you you like say
like little words and they're always
just like super disappointed you be like
you're you were talking about you just
be like
oh
man oh
crap what happened just disam ever he
was just disappointed in my sleep I
probably was at at Hamilton or something
oh you kept saying
a yeah I was probably watching the
Oscars and then and then Co my buddy he
his phone like it was like middle of the
night somehow he turned over and his
phone went on the floor he went oh damn
damn like you had just been awake all
day it was fun it was really fun yeah
you guys both snored though and I don't
think I snored I was sleeping if I did
well okay good yeah lucky you dude I
didn't hear
it um I turn on that white noise what
else is dude White Noise I've always
White Noise should just be like somebody
just like helping their kid with
homework you know it's just like things
that white people do you
know make a bunt
cake it's just an older couple listening
to Willie Nelson on their front porch
well you always hear about bartool like
oh they're [__] you know that's a shady
organization what are these guys up to
you know they're going to get busted for
money laundering like you always hear
like which is they're always on the cusp
of things you know yeah it's not out of
the question yeah they're they're kind
of like the Richard Nixon of the um of
like online you know a lot of and a lot
of people don't know what it is either
that's the thing I didn't know what it
was I was like I didn't know if it was
going to be like one of those drunk
buses that's going around town and like
and you got to Pedal it I was like yeah
Reno yeah God
I oh I will tell you this we were there
one time huge snowstorm hit a bunch of
chicks like uh all our shows got
cancelled we had to stay there for four
days yeah and two buses of like co-eds
like chicks for like going to their
sorority ski trip they couldn't go up
the mountain so they had to stay there
and they Dro them all literally me and
my buddy Jamie lisso were sitting at the
bar like man our life suck and [__]
250 women roll in that's a movie what
happened sex bro really yep let's go
pretty good done I mean not pretty brief
sex you know yeah winter sex some
wrestling yeah yeah I should have tagged
somebody in I'm good I'm good at se I'm
good
like I'm good like the pre you know when
the guy walks to the ring yeah and the
music's playing dude and they're
checking him down and the big black guy
shows up and Pats him down or whatever
that's but four four play yeah I'm good
at that I'm good at [__] let's you
know let's be ready yeah we ready I'm
good at all the intro music and
everything it's just once it starts I
think sometimes it's just too much I
don't know if it's the viscosity or what
it is and then some so but I'm yeah I'm
just not a distance Runner I'm more of a
shot
put yeah hey you know but that mean that
that's in the
Olympics and people make careers off
that they're not I don't think it's good
ones I think you probably have another
one as well wonder if I'd be a good
Muslim or
not I don't know you ever thought about
doing it I don't I think you have to be
you have to be born into it or you can
just do it I think you can did just do
it
yeah huh would you try
it maybe I tried keto for like I guess
almost a month
m kind of makes you smell bad though
doesn't it which one
keto
yeah there's a little dose of your own
medicine there do you watch his movie
morbius I went to the premiere how was
it I don't think those are my kind of
movies you know well me neither I didn't
see it for that reason it was I mean I'm
actually a huge fan of his but uh yeah I
didn't watch it um and I didn't like
bats you know we didn't have a lot of uh
I don't think we had a lot of bats
growing up around our area and so I
didn't really know anything about bats
and so I think a lot of it I was trying
to just figure out what bats get the
whole concept of it you know what are
they yeah yeah why are
they
yeah yeah dude I'll tell you a movie you
would hate
what Batman oh yeah have you seen that
dude the whole thing I don't want to
spoil it the whole thing's like bat
Centric oh
oh you probably get some more
exclamation and Clarity on like what it
is but you really probably would not
like it at all you know there's [__] you
can light it on fire that's what I read
somewhere the bat um droppings or
whatever heard you could light it on
fire that's just a myth I don't know
where if you know I don't know if that
could be true my girlfriend her mom when
I went to LSU was the women's athletic
director and uh some girl some girl on
the LSU soccer team told me that their
team was
um having to take uh creatine that's
when creatine came out it was that big
hitter you know what I'm saying you
didn't take creatine it was making baby
milk hard and the tit like it was doing
bad stuff you know babies were having to
[__] you know really squeeze the tit
to get something out of it thick milk
and um oh I took it do but he said that
the but anyway I one of the girls on the
soccer team told me that the girls on
the soccer team had to take it the coach
made him do it so next thing you know I
put all these flowers up around campus
one night the coach's name was photoplus
I think he ended up marrying a um a
famous uh female soccer player but I
wrote these signs that said fapa Hitler
and put them all over campus right next
thing you know I got a couple of my
friends that were H cappers bro a couple
real handicaps Vans and everything you
know what I'm saying people that were
going deep people at 50/50 on if they
were going to live through their diploma
you know right so and I got them to come
out in wheelchairs and everything and
like assistant Vans and uh pick it the
next morning so uh my girlfriend's mom
is women's a wait wait wait wait to pick
at the creatine pick it yeah like
outside of the women's athletic like no
yeah no more creatine like uh you're
making Crea tis that's what's one of the
sound said like just really vague
[__] uh don't quit dirtying up that
these uh yeah the livers the ovaries we
were [__] dropping some crazy [__]
right so next thing you know there's
news coverage out there there's like
handicapped kids like just cheering like
and literally there's one point where
the mom comes down she's like what in
the [__] is going on Theo like you stay
in my house this weekend why didn't you
say there was an
issue um because I was seeing her
daughter and at that point you heard
like this van come up this super
handicap van like a twostory like this
dude was handicapped with flex and you
know and uh like he'd have [__] stay
over you know and you heard like we got
reinforcements and that's when you knew
like damn this [__] was getting real and
anyway we made a fake news story out of
what was going on did it cause a rift in
your relation it cause yeah she and I
yeah and then they found some I was
using uh
I think test 200 at the time and I left
some [__] dirty you know NE dirty uh
hypodermic needles at their house and it
was just a bad weekend overall but um
what a hypocrite yeah it's a good point
huh I didn't think about that I didn't
[__] think about that dude I wonder
if the mom ever thought that yeah I just
thought like well [__] yeah I'm in a
dorm of course I can do steroids but you
can't make these chicks do them you know
all right so the Bible mhm he's like you
got the Bible you got Adam yep he did it
to you too you got Eve mhm you got their
two sons mm where' all other people come
from Big Talk how do you get the Chinese
how do you get Japanese
blacks
Mexicans other people that's what he
that's awesome yeah it was a lot of fun
I like being in there and seeing Glenny
in there and I love seeing them you know
that's why I always every guest I'm like
you met Glenny balls yet and if they say
no I'm like boy you're in for it yeah
it's just it's like it's just such a
uh he does and you don't see that in the
W you don't see that in the wild and his
Legend's growing yeah or you don't see
that in captivity that's just something
you see in the wild yeah and in some
ways I try to make sure I don't I just
let him you know let him be yeah we go
to a new city we went to Tampa last week
for Ric Flair MH and I knew he's gonna
get there a couple days early he's gonna
leave at a couple days late and he's
going to be in Tampa for a while he'll
show up for a 15-minute interview and
he'll eat some ice cream but he'll be in
Tampa for a while yeah man he's almost
like a warm
front can't control him when he's coming
you don't know where he's leaving you
don't know what he's going to but you
know some people's gonna be wet that's
all you
know you were like a real king there man
I mean you must have really I mean we
went five and seven I think right which
is very good for UNCC or Duke football
either one of those yeah I mean going
playing football Carolina is kind of
like like being a sushi chef at a
chocolate Cheesecake Factory it's like
you know they might want the sushi but
they didn't come for the football it's
for the basketball yeah this is someone
who said what would it take to basically
make up for slavery or this is someone
that said we should do this they want to
do this in Francisco they want to give
$5 million to every they weren't even
any slaves in San
Francisco they don't even do
[Music]
it dude that's a [__] great San
Francisco literally means no slaves
yeah it means without Francisco dude
that's they're acting up wow that's true
man I think it's a good idea yeah I see
where they're coming from oh yeah I get
the understanding but it's like yeah I
think dude you're G to have a lot of
people dying their skin and moving over
there
okay bro I would definitely dog you
gonna have I'm putting tannins in I'm
doing everything bro I'm taking collagen
blockers whatever I got to do bro I'm
drinking ink I'm [__] getting in do
yeah dude I would do
slavery I would be a slave dude for a
year or something this morning we did
like conditioning M which I never do
like when I stopped playing football I
was like dude I'm never I'm never doing
anything athletic again for the rest of
my life really I was like I'm never
working out like this is the stupidest
thing like I worked out so hard for my
whole life I'm never working out again
wow which and I did it for a while and
you start feeling real bad you know so
anyways I started doing I'm pretty much
still feeling bad yeah yeah you got to
start feeling good man but we did
conditioning this morning I felt so much
better after doing a conditioning than
just a lifting weights and I asked will
I was like why why do you think it feels
so much better to do conditioning he's
like well you just go kind of like you
can really exert yourself hard as you
can I feel like that's kind of the same
thing with wrestling or you can't not
you can't like half ass wrestling you
get your ass beat right so that's
something there's something to that
makes your your brain feel better at
least a little yeah I think I think I
know what you're talking about but um I
like going to I sorry didn't me
interrupt you I was just saying I said
all that but then I realized about
conditioning I didn't try my hardest at
all yeah I was like like what if I'm not
trying yeah I wasn't I wasn't condition
sucks condition does suck dude and then
the only thing I realize I'm
conditioning before I get back home and
it's just me again you know like damn
yeah now I'm you know I'm just alone
again dude I guess I'll make a taco
surely you think about women and stuff
yeah oh yeah all the time okay so but
then how do you prevent it from getting
to that sexual space where you're
thinking about pleasuring yourself or
rubbing your body on the carpet until
you
ejaculate uh it it just never gets to
that point do you think it's cuz like
you have good self-control or do you
think that you were just blessed with
like a unper verted disposition so
you're
just you just kind of lucked out
basically yeah I think it's a mixture of
both that's the part I have trouble
believing sometimes and I don't mean I'm
not calling you out about it but H do
you feel like dormant do you feel like
your Wier is
dormant yeah pretty much d That's
[__]
crazy sometimes I think about like just
those names like the the strip clubs
that serve food yeah tits and grits eggs
and legs yeah you get like hangers and
bangers old saggy saggy saggy boobs no
bras and this where potatoes
oh dude when I see a horrible tit it
[__] makes my whole body
hurt it really does man the area between
our butts and our balls are getting
smaller and smaller because I guess cuz
there's plastic in our
water of all even hearing yourself say
that sounds really crazy I was just
thinking dude
what if we could figure out a way to
reverse it and and expand the
taint and get up here yeah I love that
bro you can tell how someone's Health
just by how tall their balls
were dude I thought about getting my
balls completely taken off right yeah so
it's just all ween or no balls imagine
that
dude I bet chicks with dig Dad if you're
like hey it's all dick no nuts
honey can you imagine looking at that
yeah but still I think it seem was so
much more aerodynamic you know it would
look so good oh it'd be like a [__]
it'd be like a like a Lamborghini down
there you know but sometimes I feel like
it's like a nice like little bed kind of
like kind of like a hammock
almost resting yeah it would just have
no no friends no one to hang out with
and your penis would end up not to be
gross end if getting in touching your B
oh that's a good point now you're
talking
yeah that's true you'd have a lot more
propensity to maybe do self gaying dude
you get out of the sauna you got your
blood flowing all of a sudden you even
know what's happening dude some guys's
in class he's just shoving his wiener
into his butt for no reason just because
he's bored yeah hey Randy what are you
doing back there like a my
bad killing time
they thought you a
no dude I was I was giving speeches I
mean I was I was elevated to the type of
type of character where dude I'm not
kidding I was in uh that's awesome bro
the height of my entire college career
was and not necessarily because I'm like
a pervert or or you know I'm like sex
crazy or anything like that but just
when I knew that I had I had kind of
made it for college I got to give a
speech dude to this this sorority called
zetah M uh which is like at Carolina was
one of the top sororities and I got to
give them a speech at their banquet
about like they're about to like
graduate dude I was about to graduate I
was still in school and I gave them a
speech about like what they should do
like a like a commencement spe speech
and I was still in school and I was like
dude like and I was inside it was all
girls I was inside their sorority house
and I was giving a speech it's online I
mean you can watch a speech I'm not sure
if it was uh you know I don't know if it
would move you but yeah uh it moved me
yeah you know I remember there was this
homeless dude and he he would kept all
his teeth in his pocket and when he
would smile he so he didn't have any
teeth left when he would smile he would
just go like
this and show you his teeth and his hand
so he would smile like with his mouth
and he would get him out and
[__] and show you all of them so you
got to respect that kind of [__] these
guys who professional golfers are not
even that good of athletes uhuh they
don't seem to be yeah there there a lot
of fats yeah a lot of fats dude I've
seen a couple of them on Broadway oh
dude I saw John Dy one night overdose on
I don't even know what it was Jin I
think and get carried out of a b like
get carried out of a restaurant yeah not
even at a bar
dude what restaurant was it uh it was
12:30 club downtown
yeah now look it's a great establishment
it's that kind of place where you could
have so much fun that you got to have a
you know they got to send an ambulance
for you because you know you're whole
vibe is on fire but yeah they had they
had some dudes carrying them out and one
dude like fire like firemen carried him
you know I keep on waiting for this to
like have like a joke in it but so far
it seems seems pretty accurate to what
happened yeah and I I just turned into
on one of those people that just found
like video on him I didn't put it up cuz
it felt kind of embarrassing but and but
the crazy thing was I saw it happen
again Where They Carried John Daly out
of a out of a place I mean it probably
happens to him pretty often yeah I think
he's definitely become kind of like the
cat like he's like the bag you know he's
the bag of clubs dude can you imagine
have to carry him oh I can't even
imagine either the cad him out dude so
one how great is Beetlejuice he would be
my number one I've been trying to get
him what happened well he apparently he
like lives in Georgia he just is in
Georgia like you go down there you can
see him like he's in a town he like goes
to the store people know where he's at
but yeah huh I'll beat the [__] out of
him yeah dude they would ask about
anything you like hey your grandfather's
dying like I'll [__] him
up Beetle Juice don't give a damn dude
they like hey what do you think about
Mike Tyson I [__] Mike Tyson I'll [__]
him up I'll [__] him up right now you
don't give a [__] dude they're like
Beetlejuice you we heard that
Beetlejuice was talking [__] to you like
I'll [__] beet juice I'll [__] that guy
up I'll [__] him up [__]
him you know I was working at barcel
trying to figure out what kind of
content I was making or like what where
was my Lane so I was just trying a bunch
of different stuff so one time and I
love John guden you remember the coach
John gud oh yeah uh you were on an email
chain with him weren't you I was on an
email chain with him that I should not
have been
on yeah yeah but anyway so I was like
all right this is what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna this is when he was not coaching
he was just doing his football show all
right I was like I'm going to do a
segment and in hindsight and saying out
loud it sounds dumb and it was yeah I'm
like I'm just going to find
him finding John CR like just find them
and there was no like there was no like
find them and then I'm gonna it was like
I'm just gonna find them and uh so
anyways I was like doing all this
research talking to people who
[Music]
knew and so replying to Bucks fans DMS
yeah so I was like I was like I'm gonna
find this guy anyways I ended up in
Tampa and they're like he he his
headquarters is in the Hooters the
original Hooters oh wow like that's
where he runs his show from that's where
he shoots his show from Wow and so I was
like all right so I went to the original
Hooters I was at the restaurant and it's
in Tampa and I was eating I was like you
guys seen John Gruden recently and
they're like yeah every
day I was like well where's his office
it's in here right they're like oh no no
no it's in corporate like and that's
corporate right across the street across
the parking lot wow so you're there huh
and did you wear something nice you just
wore just regular clothes yes wore
regular clothes wow cool early in my
career yeah yeah I wasn't even at the
close stage of being in your
career and uh I walked across the street
and I went into the corporate office and
I was like I'm here to see John Gruden
and the by the way corporate office of
Hooters
okay and uh damn bro that's the
corporate office too of the world when
you think about it it's the corporate
office of every 11 and 12 and 13 and 14
and 15 year old boy I mean I got my hat
on and this was I didn't even know we
were telling the story today um but
anyway so baby them tits boy so I go in
there and I was like I want to see John
Gorden they just took me back like take
take to his office yeah he wasn't there
but his assistant gave me a tour and he
like what are you looking for him for I
like oh I don't even remember what I
said
oh was here to see him you know and yeah
yeah so show me around to the office
this is where they shoot this this is
where he does this and they're like this
is uh John Daly's room and I was like
what do you mean John Daly's room and
they're like and they open it up it's a
you know like The Chronicles of Narnia a
wall that has a bunch of books and you
can push it open yeah it was literally
that you push it open and it was just a
very small room smaller than this room
and it had a mattress on the floor and
like a little putting thing and I guess
John Daly lives in there wow really
inside inside John Gruden's office
inside the Hooters
headquarters and he and they said he
Parks his bus back and then whenever he
just needs a place to be outside his bus
he goes in there oh wow so he goes and
stays in a bus also yeah that's almost
the most Hess [__] you can do I feel
like like live in a Hooters and live in
a like be in a bus but I guess if you
love living in a bus dang and so did it
have like a sink or anything in there
yeah I think it's probably just cuz
people get so I mean if you're trying to
carry him back yeah you know you don't
want to walk up the stairs onto the bus
so sometimes it's probably just easier
if it's a smaller person he's at the
restaurant with small people maybe he's
eating Chinese or something yeah it's
take him right into the L on the ground
damn I can't believe that dude see
that's a good top secret way to go about
business a lot of businesses I feel like
think too much like let's put the
business in this big business you know
Applebees yeah they're like oh every
time you go in you know who every you
know everybody's doing Applebees bro but
it'd be crazy as [__] if you look under
like a a table or you move a booth and
there's like a Marathon gas back in
there or something yeah there was just a
big computer John guden
Gmail if you watch the news it's always
bad cuz those stories do numbers people
like those stories yeah so yeah get some
fresh yeah somebody gets a you know a
thing of fresh eggs or something nobody
gives a [__] right exactly if somebody's
like oh Brandon got a couple fresh eggs
from his buddy two people going to click
on thata yeah they might actually a lot
of people if that's just the headline it
just depends on the demographic you're
running that on I think that's true too
man as an internet article that probably
could do well perform well I think yeah
Filipino audience would go big man
they're really into the [__] eggs how
was that Drake what was that Drake
experience like going there did you go
to his house yeah oh wow yeah and does
he have like how many front doors does
he have I feel like he' have like a
front door and then if you're they let
like somebody lets you into that one but
it's not even him and you get closer and
closer and finally he lets you in like a
real yeah we were in his house for
probably like probably 90 minutes or two
hours before I saw him oh really yeah
wow yeah it was an insane awesome
experience he's my favorite artist ever
wow ever to be able to like meet him and
like go to his house and like meet his
kid who the door when you got
there not Drake huh no no no he has a
dude his security is insane good luck
dude I would like to see the [__]
busing boys try to run up with their
teeth in there with some guns trying to
get that Drake dude good luck dude
there's so many he has the most security
you ever seen security uh I've seen
imagine more
wow okay you're not get to this guy no
chance well you know what I'm talking
about they had a lady big breast lady um
type that
in
actually I think we have a Blocker on
this computer and I got to get a new one
dude I've ended up masturbating the past
4 days oh really cuz when we were at
that camp with Jimmy John you were on a
no
masturbation uh I think you were like 35
days in or something I was doing good
and I was trying to convince you to to
jerk it off I was like where you
going you're like dude why do you keep
wanting me to jerk off and I started
feeling bad about myself like I don't
know why I wanted to jerk off yeah bro
that was a weird Flex from you bro
there's no way you you can you can't
there's no way you can park in front of
those and not get a ticket huh do you
think there could be a place where this
is kind of a good look at that one dude
oh my God what what do you think what
what is she
teaching dude is she is she in white
face go up oh she probably is like
Lester
Holt he's a white dude I've always long
thought that yeah he has a very like
[Music]
um there you
go
I mean that's that's white faed how can
you have huge tits and have a look on
your face like you're looking at huge TS
at the same
time wait she teaches a wood chopping
class yes
yes of course she does baby there's a
lot of wood in there
[Laughter]
dog can you believe this
the blonde High School teacher went
viral after being filmed operting a cut
off saw in
class look at this
[__] but bro that's who's building our
[__] houses now that's why there's a
back order bro on everything
cuz this lady got her [__] T caught
in the
saw was an Oakville school teacher
it refused to identify the educator
while warning the wrong person had been
named in online
reports dude wait say that
again um they names they misidentify who
it
was oh my bad dude I'm
sorry uh we're sorry Miss
Jackson uh we're sorry Professor Arnold
we uh we just had a typo dude there's no
way that broad would make it off the
dock I mean there were some dang God
damn bro bro if one of those bounc into
the street a kid would go get it dude
those things are
[__]
[__] these things are way worse off
than anybody that works at that brownie
shop I mean these are the craziest
looking tis I've ever [__] seen
I'm sorry man I didn't mean to go in all
of that dude who sells that shirt dude
by the way who sells who sells clothing
for this type of
body yeah who sells that shirt Lulu
melons
dude when I was in college somebody
would they had a bear people would bring
this beay that had been declawed and you
could [__] wrestle it and then they
had this thing I didn't do this but
somebody had a group called fist fights
and it was gay men would fight each
other in a wrestling ring and um and you
did that too no I should have probably I
would have [__] lost but I think I
would have ranked dude have you ever
been to uh but but you could watch him
and beted on him and stuff and it was
like a big night at the bar you know
[__] fighting yeah yeah it was like it
like the original [__] fighting kind of
and it wasn't I mean they called
themselves fist fights it wasn't like
people were like oh this is what this is
you know um other people in the streets
called it you know possibly game in
fighting each other what are you doing
at 3:00 in the afternoon in Nashville
what are you going to do you want to
take a break what are you
doing I don't know maybe go for a like
go out
to the um Lake over there and go run or
something you're not doing that dude
you're not you're not doing that dude
you asked me today you're like hey you
want to go on a run and then uh before
the podcast I was like sure and then
you're like yeah I don't really want to
do that so let's just [__] not do
that I didn't want to do it either to be
honest with you I was like I guess that
sounds
fun you're like no I don't yeah that
fell apart fast boy that [__] fell apart
fast dude but you know what I think
you're going to have start to have a lot
of people that are going to be doing
this identification thing out
of not boredom but out of I want
something different in my life yeah I've
been a you know I'm not married or or
whatever or I want to get out of my
marriage I'm going to per say I'm in a
woman you know so then at least easy way
I think a lot of people are going to
start using this to get out of different
scenarios and why not it's not a bad
idea not at all your kid comes home
you're like I'm not your
dad I'm identifying as not your dad I'm
Rhonda you look like my
dad yeah but look at these tits out of
gu in the mail that's going to change
fast [__] up I mean I feel damn fancy
saying this there's two ice baths now in
my damn dude like what's even the
purpose have you ever even had someone
come over and do it with you before
never this is the first time that was
the closest thing I've ever been
probably
to kind of queering around with somebody
dude
honestly I don't know if that's or just
not I don't want to say that that was
probably the most
the bravest thing I've done with another
man it's like 32 degrees out too so it's
not even warm when you get out dude I
just feel like I just got to recover for
a minute yeah I feel like a bunch of
snow just tried to [__] me that's what I
kind of feel like the weird thing though
is you feel like when you're in it you
feel good after the first two minutes
you feel like I was could to swam in
there kept saying that oh yeah like if a
seal would have swam up would have been
like oh hey
I feel like it would have been very at
least they are separate the two ice
paaths yeah yeah
bro dude there's nothing I don't think
is there
anything is there anything more homo
homoerotic than two men in one ice bath
together dude do you think anyone okay
this is a weird question do you think
it's possible physically possible after
10 minutes being the ice bath to get an
erection in it you C you can't leave oh
no way no way you can say anything could
happen like any type of visual mental
simulation you
need wow that's a great that would be
almost better I feel like than Dana
White slap fight I think you know
watching that like and they had an
underwater cam first to pop yeah first
to pop dude and we're just the refs on
the
side but it would have to be a clear
tank you know and Al I think you'd have
to get a certain like it'd be so hard to
get it all the way to the
top there's also a school for hockey
kids who don't want to go to real school
and it's awesome they literally just
don't go to real school they do online
classes and they play hockey all day in
Nashville in Nashville wow and they have
every age so we'll go in there as we
work out and we'll like jump in the
sauna showers and then we're just shower
there's a bunch of middle schoolers
running around making fun of each
other's meats and stuff like that why is
he not not getting naked you know so
we're just in there listening to it but
it's like man this is really this is
really what uh what being a guy's all
about my god
dude yeah dog look I've been through
some [__] man we've all been through
some [__]
dude that's crazy bro I never uh I don't
know some kid I remember tried to show
me his dick bro and I told him no yeah
and I was thankful for that man um but
kids are ruthless oh they don't care
like we'll sitting there and we'll be in
the sauna and they'll all be like
waiting in line to get in the showers
and stuff and they ruthless yeah they're
so mean dude I like God these getting
roasted right you want to step in be
like I'm not stepping in it's dangerous
over there and you don't know the lingo
stepping down in a young age bracket is
way scary dude Terri Terri and kids
nowadays it's like they're so on their
iPad they don't even notice if they get
molested I feel like well you know I
feel like a lot of kids wouldn't even
yeah true you know know I don't know
that's insane we might have to take that
out dude well by the time we
get but I mean I
mean like when I was young you weren't
looking at your iPad so like you know
you noticed if you really noticed you
were somebody's iPad
yeah you noticed yeah but nowadays you
can't even get the kids attention
probably probably I go in and they put
me under anesthesia and I go on a
ventilator they basically didn't give me
a choice they're like you want that or
you want a tra I was like I'll take the
ventilator a TR is that the thing we
have to be like yeah like I'll take the
ventilator so what would you say to
people who
[Laughter]
[Music]
say and then uh
so that' be the craziest if you had one
of those smokers things like what would
you say to people who say are you the
throat
goat I'm on this ventilator and they
have my arms strapped down and I'm on
anesthesia like on all the drugs drug
you know the drugs the drugs I was on
all of them I'm [__] strapped down
the only thing they don't want me to do
is pull out my ventilator and you sent
me a voice message my mom's like Oh Theo
sent you something you want to hear
they're trying to cheer me up yeah she
hits play and it's like quit being a
[__] pull that [__] out walk out like a
man sorry man I've been watching some
David goggin's videos I
think I was trying to bring you back
dude they had you on a [__]
ventilator you had a sore throat bro all
right so Michigan Illinois so we're just
going to declare a winner and you've
been through all these and you know kind
of how they got there we can I mean it's
these two have never played each other
there's the breakdown we got a video
right here from me yeah I'm glad you
said that this guy looks exactly like
Theo Jesus hey Theo this is Dennis
Michigan versus Illinois now I was born
and raised in Illinois but I went to
college at Western Michigan go
Broncos so I got to go with
Michigan
Illinois could anybody really name any
other cities or towns in Illinois
besides Chicago it's all suburbs it's
all flatland the politics are corrupt
last year 30,000 people left the state
of Illinois because of
taxes and we're too divided we don't
even like each other's baseball teams I
was one of the few people who was
rooting against the Cubs in the World
Series cuz I'm that much of a southsider
go white socks with Michigan got the
peninsula you got all that land they are
united on all fronts they got the Great
Lakes and if it's any consolation me a
person of Illinois choosing Michigan is
just further proof that Michigan takes
it gang gang dude first of all holy [__]
dude obviously I came in someone about
20 years ago near this guy's
Hometown unbelievable and this is me if
I was a little bit better looking that's
even the sadder part of it it's so crazy
how does he not mention one time I
know that he looks like me with better
looking eyes and I went to a Morgan show
too in um in Arlington you went in
Arlington it was like I think it was one
of his first stadium shows if not his
first one and it was it was one of the
best shows I've ever seen in my life so
good not to like gas it up more than we
already have but like the show itself is
like an amazing show I thought it was
over like 25
times he literally finished he did like
10 encor it was went four and a half
hours oh it's the long show he was still
there people have people went home he
was still
singing yeah dude he was he's sanging
different voices dude by the end he's
just up there like last night we
the okay I'm going through the
Charleston Airport and I got a long
flight back to New York this is a while
ago and I had taken a little bit of an
edible of of weed yeah baby huh and so
just for nothing crazy but yeah just to
get home yeah and
uh and I was as soon as I got to the
airport probably took it like 30 minutes
before I got the airport soon as I get
to the airport I'm like kind of I'm like
feeling it you know I'm just I'm a
little aware of everything that's going
on and not at the same time yeah and
this this police officer walks up to me
as I'm going through TSA and he said hey
everybody come here I oh man I was like
what's this going to be he's like hey um
we have these these bomb dogs out here
and we we're testing them we need we
need you to walk through TSA and we're
going to give you this little uh it was
like a little packet he's like you just
put in your pocket and it smells like a
bomb he's like just walk through TSA
like you're normal and just we're going
to see if the dogs
notice so I'm high as a
kite walking through TSA and I just got
attacked by a dog the week
before
understand
and finally it's my time it's it's my
time to go through the thing and I'm
looking at the dogs I'm looking around
and by the way they didn't tell other
people in TSA line oh because it's a
long TSA line with a hundred other
people yeah that's
miscommunication and so I walked through
and of
course Jing up on me I'm losing my mind
I'm freaking out the whole Airport's
looking this guy's got a
bomb Oh damn bro my grandma she watched
Fox News every night like religiously
and what happened to her she passed away
she passed away she got di she got
diagnosed with Alzheimer's and um when
she got diagnosed with Alzheimer's
Tucker was doing a lot of stuff with
barcalo at the time with Dave Dave was
going on his show a lot and so I knew
people at barcel knew him I never met
him I still have never met him but I
said I would really like to do something
nice for my grandma right now so I asked
our booking people do you think there's
any way Tucker Carlson could like I know
it's a crazy ask he's probably busy and
whatever but like worth asking would he
like make a video for my grandma oh and
he made this video and sent to me it was
like a two-minute video just being so
nice she didn't remember at all I don't
think she even knew he
was but like just the fact he did it's
like you know they're people too you
know it's like I know people hate him or
whatever but oh last night you let the
lier
talk that was your grandmother sorry she
told me to tell you that
[Music]
no it's interesting like people be like
I'm having anxiety about my schoolwork
it's like you haven't done your [__]
school work that's why you don't know
nothing about it yeah dude it's due in
seven hours and you're about to go to
sleep that's not anxiety youve [__]
done your work like that's the weird
thing about the word anxiety it's just
getting really really like kind of toss
around and everything another thing
about Illinois yeah how how do you say
it I say it Illinois because
I that's how I say it too which means
that there's a silent s which is in a in
a lot of ways suspicious yeah I don't
know any other states that have silent
letters and why would you need a
AR Arkansas yeah right yeah nobody says
arkans and that's and that's evidence D
they're hiding something you think or
they want you know what it's like it's
kind of like they want
to they you know they know you know but
they just don't want you to say it well
it's a blinking country man you got
that's top hats that's people have
[__] balancing [__] tall hats on
their heads for decades that's the
posture belt I think that me and you
probably got pretty good heights yeah
well I like I you know I I do get
admirable of your height well I'm 6'1 I
went to I moved to Florida and I had to
get a new ID and I always said I 6'2
when I was playing football oh yeah
because you always go an inch inch more
but then uh once I finally just admitted
I'm like I'm 6'1 that's what what it is
so I go to DMV and I had Co I think at
the time went to DMV I didn't know but
it turned out later so
by the way you see what the santis did I
don't want to no we already talked about
it the other day on here it's so awesome
hilarious but so cool some people I've
read somewhere that rich people were
showing up to pet the [__] people and
[__] but I went to the DMV and I was
like she's like how tall are you I said
61 and she sent me gave me my ID print
they printed out right there it said 63
oh really I said 63 she
said like kind of like who gives a [__]
dude you to take it or not want give it
back it'll be
5'9 dude that's [__] awesome I feel
like New York City's gotten so
gentrified so rich whatever you call it
you
know that there's not you can't even get
mugged anywhere any except for Al
Alphabet City you can't even get [__]
stabbed except for an alphabet City the
OD getting shot in New York City anymore
you better [__] you're going to have
to drive over to you know to New Jersey
right over to New Jersey right to really
get like Hoboken is kind of like a place
that regular people can afford to live
now Brooklyn I mean that like dude I saw
some graffiti in there it was like Larry
sucks dick right in the urinal and it
said but only if he's okay with it right
like they're so [__] liberal it's
like what the [__] are they really going
to like fight or throw down they going
to pick it they going to protest but now
then you get up to Rochester dude with
that's the overdose belt bro up in the
rooc do with [__] people listening to
brother we and then morning on the radio
and eating dirty Italian and celebrating
same St Patrick's Day nine times a year
those [__] with the neck
tattoos and [__] square wheel roller
skates those [__] are getting
bent bro I had uh uh bobon you know him
like tallest guy in the
NBA oh he played for the Mavs he's got
traded to the Rockets bo b similar okay
but his name is Bo Bon Bo Bon okay he's
like the new version basically and uh I
asked him I was like dude and this is we
haven't put this out yet but I was
like when you get like how long does it
take you to get a boner dude to get that
signal down to your dick you get horny
in like 25 minutes later yeah you got
bad
thfi [__] ain't going up now I'm just
floating on the breeze and I feel I'm
falling like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of mind I
found I can feel it in my bone
but it's going to
take